Hey, Vsauce. Michael here.
And today we are going to talk about color.
(Green Green, Green Green).
"Gold" on, let me just "Pink" this up.
"Yellow?"
"Michael, "Orange" you going to come to the
concert this evening?"
"I "Red" about that, there are going to be
a lot of "Purple" there."
"I didn't "Teal" you about this earlier?"
"Well, look, I have to go "Brown" town first,
but I'll be "White Black."
Colors...
Did you know that the human eye can differentiate
10 million different colors? But what color
is a mirror?
You might say "silver," because mirrors are
often illustrated that way, and, to be sure,
they are made out of silver or silvery things
like aluminium. But a mirror, in reality, is
whatever color you point it at.
In this Green Room, the mirror is green. And
if you look inside a mirror, it becomes "you-colored."
An object is whatever color it doesn't absorb.
These sticky notes are orange because when
hit with typical white light, they absorb
every other wavelength of visible light, except
for orange, which they diffuse into your eye balls.
But a perfect mirror reflects all colors equally.
So, in a way, you could say that a mirror
is white, except a mirror doesn't reflect
colors in the same way that pigment does.
A mirror reflects incoming light in a single
outgoing direction - specular reflection, not
diffuse. This kind of reflection creates an
image of the very thing in front of the mirror.
So, as Bad Astronomy jokes,
a mirror is more of a "smart white."
But wait a second, that is a "perfect" mirror
and we live in the real world where there
are no perfect mirrors. Every mirror absorbs
a little bit of light, not enough that it
matters, I mean, it looks pretty clear to
me, but when you take a look at the spectrum
of light reflected by a typical mirror, you
will find that it best reflects light within
the 510 nanometer range, which we perceive
as green light. So, technically, a mirror
is a tiny, tiny, tiny bit green.
You may have noticed this yourself
when investigating a "Mirror Tunnel."
This happens when two mirrors face each other,
reflecting the same scene back and forth,
and back and forth, and back and forth. With
each new reflection, a little bit more visual
light is lost, but green least of all. That's
why the reflection way down the tunnel is
dimmer and greener.
So maybe real world mirrors aren't "smart
white," they're actually kind of green, but
we should talk about white.
"En español, "white" es "blanco."
"En français, "white" est dit "blanc."
And in English we have a word that comes
from the same route. Black, which is the opposite
of white. How did that happen?
Well, it turns out that all of those words
come from the same ancient Proto-Indo-European
root word "Bhleg," which meant "shine," "burn,"
"flash." Some languages took it to mean the
brightness of the flash: "white." While others
took it to mean what's left behind: the burned,
"black," darkness.
If you have blue eyes, your eyes aren't actually
blue, in the sense that the molecules inside
them are absorbing all other wavelengths of
visible light and diffusing the blue. No,
no, no, instead, your eyes are blue for the
same reason that the sky is blue: interference.
In our sky, light from the Sun encounters
molecules of air and because of the size
of those molecules, light of longer wavelengths
can slip on by, but shorter wavelengths crash
into the particles, like blue light, and scatter,
which is why we see blue when we look at the
sky away from the Sun.
Without the air molecules, that space would
just be black. And when direct sunlight has
to travel through a lot of air, almost all
of the colors get scattered out except for
the longest wavelengths, the red, which is
what gives a sunrise and a sunset their color.
The iris of your eyeball contains a hazy layer
where light can be scattered just like the
sky. Through a similar, but slightly different
process, shorter wavelengths are scattered
more, making your eyes look blue, unless,
of course, you have some melonen in that iris,
in which case your eyes are going to be
green, hazel or brown.
Enjoy those colors.
And as always,
thanks for watching.